nicolas hulot vous êtes un passionné
d'aventuré on vous connaît au travers de
vos émissions de télévision et là vous
venez de remettre hier donc le prix elle
comme aventure donc avec simon pour son
roman le voyageur magnifique alors
est-ce que l' aventure ça peut se vivre
aussi dans sa tête puisque là il s'agit
en fait d'un roman qui les poteaux
biographique ça se passe dans la tête
dit simon vous savez toute aventure je
crois prend naissance dans l'imagination
peut-être même dans l'imaginaire je
pense qu'il frontière commune entre les
aventures réalisé et le monde de
l'imaginaire la plus belle aventure des
dernières années par exemple celle
aventures de la lune et moi je citerai
une phrase d'un homme d'état
extraordinaire qui a dit au moment où il
a lancé le programme apollo
c'était kennedy il a dit en anglais il
faut une can dream it we can do it qui
ont pleuré mais on peut le faire je
crois que ce pourrait être la devise de
tous les aventuriers on enfin en ce qui
vous concerne l'aventuré vécue aussi au
quotidien puisque vous la vivez dans
l'action reste que en ce qui vous
concerne ça a commencé l'aventuré dans
votre tête aux 6 mois alors on rêve
qu'on est tout petit davanture lointaine
et puis un jour je crois qu'il ya un
temps effectivement pour le rêve et puis
selon décide de se cantonner au stade du
rêveur soit un moment on veut toucher du
doigt le rêve et il faut passer donc du
rêve à la réalité
c'est pas le plus facile encore faut-il
en avoir l'opportunité et les
possibilités la liberté parce que l
aventure c'est aussi un espace de
liberté
ben moi j'ai décidé de franchir le pas
aussi souvent que possible
et puis d'en faire profiter le plus
grand nombre pour que certaines
personnes veulent inventer un peu par
procuration alors justement alain
bombard est un des aventuriers type je
crois qu'on le connaît surtout au
travers de sa traversée de l'atlantique
sur un radeau sur un bateau pneumatique
est ce que vous pensez comme lui que la
nouvelle forme d' aventure vécue au
travers du sponsoring des natures
laventure j'allais dire de nos ancêtres
écoutez je crois que le mot aventure
c'est un mot qu'il faut employer avec
parcimonie et avec prudence parce que je
pense que la grande aventure avec un a
majuscule aller d'une époque révolue
alors aujourd'hui on est tous des
enfants spirituels des stanley charcot
livingston et compagnie mais c'est vrai
qu'à côté de on n'est vraiment pas grand
chose alors on a peut-être des goûts et
des passions communes et des pulsions
identique à celle qu'ils avaient à leur
époque mais je pense que la vraie
aventure elles datent donc d'une époque
passée à la rouge
aujourd'hui les démarches ne sont pas
les mêmes il faut dire que les besoins
sont pas les mêmes je dire que l'époque
des grands découvreurs des explorateurs
est aussi terminée mise à part l'espace
et peut-être les fonds sous-marins et
l'aventuré gratuite aujourd'hui
alors moi je me garde toujours d'essayer
de référence et de catalogues l aventure
certes de maths dans la colonne de
gauche que l'on considère comme une
aventure et dans la colonne de droite ce
que l'on considère comme n'étant pas une
aventure
je crois que ce qui est important c'est
que l' aventure c'est un état d'esprit
une démarche et je dis toujours que moi
l'inventeur commence lorsque l'on nous
prend un chemin de traverse
à partir de là chacun apporte sa propre
définition de l'aventuré
le tout ce qui est ce qui est important
c'est que la personne qui a vécu quelque
chose je pense à voir avec une aventure
le reste on s'en fiche bien alors ce qui
concerne le magazine de l'extrême
est-ce que c'est difficile de mettre en
place de telles expéditions à ce que ça
demande beaucoup de préparation à ce que
ça demande beaucoup d'argent aussi de
sponsoring comment ça se passe en ce qui
vous concerne
moi en ce qui me concerne on peut pas
parler vraiment d'expédition c'est vrai
que les plateaux maintenant que je fais
c'est à dire toutes mes interventions
l'image s'apparentent à des mini
expéditions alors je fais bosser des
équipes qui travaillent alternativement
là par exemple moi je vous parle il y en
a une qui est au sahara en train de
préparer une traversée du tas signer en
montgolfière y en a une autre qui est
dans le labrador pour préparer une
randonnée en scooter des neiges est prêt
à aller en arctique en ulm peu après ont
valu au zimbabwe en hydravion
bon alors ce sont des petites
expériences qui sont pas des vrais
expédition faut quand même remettre les
choses à leur juste valeur
mais comme tout ce que l'on fait d'un
petit peu délicate faire avec une très
grande prudence vous dit ce ne sont pas
de vrais expédition enfin la tentative
que vous avez donc essayé en article je
crois c'était quand même une expédition
by apparaît entouré et ça c'est une
démarche différente c'est une expédition
que j'ai monté pour moi qui a eu des
prolongations médiatique par la suite le
départ si je faisais pas ça pour la
télévision maintenant là pour les
semaines et les mois à venir tant que
mon émission existe sur tf1 je suis un
peu coincé mais tant mieux d'ailleurs
tout ce que je fais est liée à la
télévision je le fais pour les besoins
de mon émission
tandis que quand j'ai fait le pôle nord
en ulm je les fais à des fins
personnelles par goût personnel et par
passion personnelle et donc là
effectivement je peux mettre la barre un
peu plus haut dans les dents les défis
c'est un vrai défi qu'on avait lancé à
l'article et au pôle nord et là c'est
une démarche différente mais je vais pas
me tuer pour la télévision
je pense qu'on peut distiller des
émotions et diffuser un certain nombre
de sensations mais il faut rester dans
un climat sain il faut pas tomber dans
un climat malsain où tous les
spectateurs se dit à ce que le gars qui
parle va se [ __ ] en l'air
moi c'est pas du tout ce qui m'intéresse
je pense pas que les gens me voient
comme ça les gens s'identifient un peu à
moi parce que je disais tout à l'heure
je leur fait vivre des émotions par
procuration c'est vrai quand il voit aux
commandes manuelles m au dessus de la
casamance où bientôt c'est de l'article
ou en dessous une telle est la sienne
calotte glaciaire bon moi je fais 63 kg
tout mouillé je pense pas qu'il me
prenne pour rambo ils se disent c'est
sympa il le fait il a le temps il peut
le faire et ils partagent mes faiblesses
mes doutes mes maladresses et
éventuellement mais jouer avec moi là il
ya un intérêt certain actuellement pour
l' aventure mais est ce que vous ne
pensez pas justement qui a un désir de
sensations fortes et ça va peut-être
jusqu'à ce domaine malsain que vous
évoquez en ce qui concerne le public est
ce que le public n'a pas envie jour
après jour d'avoir des émotions de plus
en plus fort moi je ne pense pas je
pense que l'émotion elle peut procéder
de plusieurs facteurs pas forcément du
facteur risque
c'est vrai que le facteur risque peut
déclencher un certain nombre d'émotions
mais la beauté des paysages la beauté
d'un geste sportif un gars qui va vous
enchaînez 3 looping
elta au dessus du kilimandjaro joue dit
n'importe quoi mais c'est un exemple
c'est pas pour autant que ce gars-là
saint furious il enchaîne trois sets 3
loupé dans l d'état c'est qu'il maîtrise
parfaitement sa discipline et son art et
que en plus si on le fait au dessus d'un
décor somptueux c'est vrai que ça ajoute
à la dimension du geste et moi l'une des
des choses à laquelle je m'attache dans
l'émission c'est justement de conjuguer
un site et un geste sportif
quand on fait un vol au dessus des
pyramides au dessus des chutes victoria
l'autre jour on a survolé les chutes
victoria en montgolfière c'était
somptueux et ça ça ne me faisait courir
de risques à personne n'était pas plus
dangereux de vol en montgolfière au
dessus des chutes victoria qu'au-dessus
de la beauce mais seulement ça prenait
une dimension différente
ce que je voulais dire c'est est-ce que
vous ne risquez pas d'être victime de ce
votre propre système
un moment où le public est habitué
toujours avoir du spectaculaire le
spectaculaire on le sait on s'y habitue
ce qu'on voit régulièrement la
télévision est ce que ne risquez pas
d'être seulement victime de ce désir
frénétique et jour après jour plus grand
des téléspectateurs de voir des choses
de plus en plus dangereuse mais c'est
pour ça je reviens ce que je disais à
l'instant c'est que si vous ne faites
vibrer les gens peu par ce côté
spectaculaire c'est à dire du gars qui
va sauter d'une falaise un peu plus
haute que son prédécesseur ou que le
type qui va tenter un truc jamais fait
et on sait pas trop si ça va passer
effectivement vous allez habitué les
gens ce climat et moi dans mon émission
j'essaie justement de prendre de la
distance vis-à-vis de ces initiatives
que je trouve un petit peu stupide moi
je pense que ce qui m'intéresse ce sont
les gens qui maîtrisent parfaitement une
discipline le bois qui odéon sait pas
trop comment ça va se terminer
j'essaie d'éviter généralement ce genre
de casse cou je les évite mois pour moi
les gens qui sont dans mon émission et
ont quand même une autre dimension que
le simple casque ou sont des gens qui
vivent comme ça toute l'année ça procède
quand même presque d'une philosophie
d'une éthique et c'est la maîtrise d'une
discipline
alors quand on vois je sais pas moi
catherine destivelle grimper sur une
falaise pour moi je la regarde sans dire
qu'elle va tomber
je la regarde en dix ans cette fille est
l'extraordinaire elle est belle ces
gestes sont beaux et cela regarde comme
je regarde un gars jouer du violon dans
un orchestre symphonique parce que je me
dis qu'est la maîtrisait à la perfection
esthétique est important voilà qui c'est
une maîtrise à la perfection d'une
discipline faut le voir comme ça
catherine destivelle cantal grimpe une
falaise le fais pas pour la première
fois on se dit pas il va tomber le va
pas tomber
en fait on est sûr qu'elle va pas tomber
parce que encore une fois elle a atteint
la perfection
est ce que nicolas hulot dans ses
aventures a déjà eu peur a connu le
stress je pense propre à tous les
aventuriers bas jour ou l'autre vous
savez je crois qu'il faut se méfier des
gens qui connaissent pas la peur moi la
peur je la connais en permanence alors
faut pas que cela soit une peur
castratrice faut pas que ce soit une
peur panique mais la peur c'est la
meilleure protectrice moi j'évite les
gens qui le connaissent pas parce que
cela ils sont sur une liste et tôt ou
tard il aura un pépin était pas que moi
il m'arrivera rien mais en tout cas la
peur en lucide et ça c'est important
alors moi j'ai peur tout le temps mais
j'avais un souvenir particulier une part
très particulière liée à une de ses
aventures
ben moi j'aime m'a été donnée souvent
l'occasion d'avoir des peurs un peu plus
violente que d'autres moi je me souviens
de la peur la plus forte que j'ai eu ça
va paraître un peu rigolo la raconter ça
ici mais parce que ça peut paraître
incroyable mais un jour je descendais
zambèze en canoë c'est une expédition
que j'avais monté entre le botswana le
mozambique à travers de zimbabwe j'avais
fait 12 100 km en canoë sans armes
je précise parce que on a une plus
grande humilité des avis des animaux
quand on n'a pas d'argent on les regarde
différemment et un moment mon canoë
alors que j'étais en train de me laisser
dériver par le courant du fleuve ces
faits soulevés par deux hippopotames
bon ben ça ça fait partie des moments
dont je me souviens parce que les gens
qui m'ont regardé à cet instant m'ont
dit que je devais pas être le seul on
été liquéfié
on était vraiment mort de peur au point
qu'on était capable de faire le
incapable de faire le moindre geste ça
ça fait partie des peurs dont je me
souviens il ya des peurs qu'on maîtrise
ce cas c'est une peur panique veut dire
d'être surpris par quelque chose et il
ya la peur avant d'oser de faire quelque
chose moi je me souviens une fois dans
la seconde tentative du pôle nord celle
qu'on a réussi
on avait préparé un axe de piste sur la
glace pour décoller on avait travaillé
trois jours consécutifs pour couper
toutes les contre les crêtes de glace et
au moment où on s'apprête à décoller on
s'aperçoit que la glace s'était fracturé
elle qui avait une fracture de libre au
milieu dax de piste bon ben on a quand
même décidé de décoller on a mis les gaz
à fond et puis on s'est dit on verra
bien si avant la hollow en tirant le
manchot d'école ou pas bon allez ça peut
être dur est de 30 secondes mais ces
trente secondes là on sue à grosses
gouttes ondées
il est moins 40 qui a dans le cockpit et
on a une vraie peur quel est votre
prochaine aventure il ya des aventures
qui seront liés un petit peu à
l'émission et puis le projet qui
m'habite hecking gratter qui va me
gratter jusqu'à ce que je les réalise et
ou en tout cas jusqu'à ce que je me
rende compte rendu compte qu'il n'est
pas faisable
j'aurais partir sur les traces d'un
fantastique aventuriers qui s'appelait
nobile qui était un ingénieur et général
l'italien qui avait traversé l'arctique
en ballon dirigeable
alors actuellement j'aimerais bien un
petit peut suivre son vol comme j'avais
suivi en ulm le vol de bird qui avait
été le premier sauvé le pôle nord en
avion et je suis en train de voir si la
technologie d'aujourd'hui nous permet de
reconstruire un dirigeable pour
traverser article je vous remercie
[Musique]